I need to work
come back come back come back but you
know the suit can take the weight right
so I take the tank fly it right up to
the General's Palace drop it at his feet
I'm like boom you looking for this
boom are you looking why do I even talk
to you guys everywhere else that story
kills that's the whole story yes War
Machine story oh it's very good then
impressive quality safe
so no pepper she's not coming
what about Jane where are the ladies
gentlemen oh miss Potts has a company to
run so I'm not even sure what country
Jane's in her work in the convergence is
made to the world's foremost astronomer
and the company that pepper runs is the
largest tech conglomerate on Earth it's
pretty exciting there's even talk of
Jane getting a um a Nobel Prize yeah
they must be busy because they'd hate
missing you guys get together
testosterone oh my goodness excuse me
but Jane's better sounds like a hell of
a fight sorry I missed it
if I had known it was going to be a
firefight I absolutely would have called
it I'm not actually sorry I'm just
trying to sound tough
very happy chasing cold leads on our
missing persons case
avenging is your world
your world is crazy be it ever so humble
you find a place in Brooklyn yet I don't
think I can afford a place in Brooklyn
well home is home you know
a flight right up to the General's
Palace I drop it at his feet I'm like
boom you looking for this
I gotta have some of that no no no see
this this was aged for a thousand years
the barrels built from the wreck of
Grundy Hill's Fleet is not meant for
Mortal men neither was Omaha Beach
Blondie stop trying to scare us come on
all right
egg shells here
[Music]